can you get a sense of Google cloud
platform data processing and data
storage products in just a few minutes
let's find out
[Music]
it all starts with the ability to store
objects or files Google Cloud Storage is
a fully managed object storage service
it offers different storage classes from
multi-regional for optimal end-user
latency to cold line storage for lower
frequency access there is a single
unified API to interact with cloud
storage this makes for instance moving
objects across storage classes
completely seamless
cloud storage offers strong consistency
and is designed for 11 nines of
durability storing data is great but
processing it is probably even more
useful in the Big Data category a GCP
hello world would be to throw an SQL
query at a large set of data hoping to
find useful insights let's do just that
with bigquery you could of course upload
and work with your own data set but here
we will use sample data from a public
data set instead what's important here
is that at no point do you need to
provision a cluster or storage capacity
simply craft a standard sequel query and
within seconds
bigquery will have processed potentially
gigantic amounts of data and produce the
result that can be saved in various
formats for instance using the public
data set of github commits here we've
asked bigquery to provide the list of
the top Google employees fixing stuff on
github also with the same data set we
can figure out which programming
languages make developers the most happy
notice the regular expression embedded
in the query the key point here is how
much data is processed in such a short
period of time you can import or stream
data to bigquery using an API but also
export just about any data produced by
other GCP products and services such as
logs to bigquery if you have existing
Apache Hadoop or SPARC workloads you
will likely be interested in trying out
cloud data proc GCPs fully managed
environment that will
spin up a cluster in less than 90
seconds let's talk about relational
databases or our dbmss SQL as the
language still has unsurpassed qualities
and our DBMS is such as MySQL and
PostgreSQL are very popular this is why
Google Cloud SQL is a managed service
that supports both of these relational
databases this is a great solution for
storing your existing or new application
there simply choose between MySQL and
PostgreSQL select a machine size with up
to hundreds of gigabytes of RAM and
terabytes of storage select a zone and
cloud SQL will take care of providing
the following encryption at rest and in
transit a private IP address data
replication between multiple zones with
automatic failover automated backups as
well as point in time recovery staying
with relational databases google also
offers cloud spanner a horizontally
scalable strongly consistent relational
database as a service make sure to check
out is truly innovative technology that
defies the cap theorem and that many
Google services are built on in the no
SQL department cloud files store is a
highly scalable strongly consistent
database offering two modes the native
mode offering real-time updates and
offline support for mobile developers
and the data store mode for back-end
developers looking for a schema list
documents database cloud BigTable will
complement your storage options with a
petabyte scale fully managed no SQL
database service this will be mostly
suited for large analytical and
operation workloads as it comes with
high throughput characteristics such as
consistent sub 10 millisecond latency in
any case you should visit cloud at
google.com slash storage options for a
decision tree to understand which is the
best database for you GCP has numerous
other data related products some
particularly innovative be sure to
consider the following pop sub for
producing and consuming messages
globally across all GTP zones and
regions file store for applications that
require a file system interface cloud
memory store for Redis provides a fully
managed in mem
datastores service that is ideal to
build application caches with submit
second data access cloud dataflow to
build and execute unified batch and
streaming pipelines using the Apache
beam programming model data prep to make
sure your data scientists are not
spending 90% of their time cleaning up
data instead of processing it and data
studio for interactive dashboards and
engaging reports consider taking free
code labs linked in the description
below to explore any of these GCB
products check out the compute overview
and machine learning episodes and look
forward to an upcoming video on DevOps
and tooling if you liked this video
please like subscribe comment and share
see you soon for another GCP essentials
video
[Music]
you